[Música]
esta es mi última hora de médica
no sé si me piden un blanqueamiento
dental en una colonoscopia no entiendo
nada entiende algo
el año pasado siete mil personas
murieron en eeuu por no entender la
letra de prescripciones como esta
la argentina no lo sabemos porque no
tenemos datos pero seguros fueron un
montón
yo me voy del consultorio en este papel
y la verdad que no entiendo nada pero
por lo menos entendí perfecto lo que me
dijeron adentro
tengo diverticulosis y el colesterol
bueno está súper alto y la presión alta
que está medio baja pero que no termino
de entender si eso es bueno o es malo
porque la verdad tampoco entiendo del
todo lo que me dicen adentro del
consultorio no es decir no es un
problema de la letra de los médicos es
un problema de cómo usamos el lenguaje
esta es una historia que cuenta antonio
un agente sanitario wichi de la
provincia del chaco dice que llega a un
pueblito un médico necesario de la
facultad de no energía con todo su saber
y lo va a visitar una pareja de criollos
le dicen ellos a los lugareños que viven
en la zona con su hijito pues su hijito
tenía
ellos dicen malaria dolor de barriga
dolor de estómago dolor de panza
el médico lo revisa lo mira y dice bueno
vayan tranquilos no pasa nada tiene una
gastroenteritis bueno sadam y al salir
la familia de preguntas y que dice el
médico que tiene en línea no nada dice
la criolla un gato enterito y seguiría
en la panza
es cuento de antonio cuenta una
situación típica de la consulta médica
antonio es agente sanitario en una zona
donde hay muchos hablantes de lengua
which is podría haber contado un montón
de historias
tristemente ciertas en las cuales
pacientes que sólo hablan wichi no se
entienden con médicos que solo hablan
español sin embargo la historia que
cuenta tiene todos los protagonistas que
hablan la misma lengua tanto el médico
como la parejita de curiosos y aún así
no se entienden porque piensan que pasa
esto
los médicos tienen un lenguaje propio un
lenguaje específico que les permite
comunicarse con otros médicos aunque nos
deje afuera los que no lo somos los
criollos también tienen un lenguaje
específico que les permite hablar del
río que les permite hablar del monte de
los animales del clima
sin embargo socialmente valoramos de
manera distinta a estas distintas formas
de hablar es decir hay una valoración
social mayor hacia las variedades
profesionales que están vinculadas a
sectores económicos y educativos más
altos mientras que hay una valoración
menor menor prestigio en las variedades
que hablan los sectores más bajos
la desigualdad lingüística es el
resultado de esta diferente valoración
que hacemos de lenguas variedades
maneras de hablar y que produce y
reproduce en cada situación de
comunicación una relación desigual entre
las personas que las hablan
ahora les voy a contar otra historia que
está división
hace unos años conocí a un joven
paraguayo vamos a marcar los que había
ido a buscar atención psiquiátrica a un
hospital en la ciudad de buenos aires la
psiquiatra que lo entrevista que lo
tiene en revista admisión con él empieza
por algunas preguntas de rutina dice
bueno tomas la medicación quien te ayuda
con la medicación y fue pasa otras
preguntas más personales porque te
peleas con tu hermano que sentís cuando
te enojas
las respuestas de carlos a estas
preguntas eran curiosamente impersonales
si no lo sé
la psiquiatra que había notado en su
cuaderno alexitimia es decir dificultad
para identificar y expresar las
emociones lee la nota de derivación y
comenta acá dice el médico que te cuesta
comunicarte y yo me acuerdo todavía
carlos la miró de frente por primera vez
y yo le dijo en castellano me cuesta
carlos era hablado por la lengua más
acostumbrado al guaraní que el español
el hospital le exigía comunicarse en un
idioma que no dominaba y estaba
dispuesto a diagnosticarlo a tratarlo a
medicar lo lo que sea en esa lengua
segunda y el guaraní ese guaraní con el
cual se hablaba de sus emociones y
argumentaba ideas complejas y contaba
historias no tenía ningún lugar no tiene
ningún valor en la institución
la desigualdad se hacía entre lenguas
distintas o entre distintas formas de
hablar la misma lengua reproduce en cada
conversación desigualdades sociales más
amplias
la desigualdad lingüística dificulta y
muchas veces impide que podamos acceder
a derechos humanos fundamentales
en argentina no tenemos información
sobre este fenómeno en investigación yo
encontré que la mitad de las personas
que se acercaban al hospital buscando
atención en salud mental la mitad no
llegaba la entrevista de admisión y de
las que lo hacían el 35% no llegaba a la
segunda entrevista es decir siete de
cada diez personas que se acercaban
buscando atención se iban con las manos
vacías y esta situación macro que afecta
a miles y miles de personas se originan
situaciones micro en conversaciones cara
a cara que tenemos con médicos médicas
docentes compañeros y compañeras de
trabajo
estas dos historias tienen mucho para
decirnos acerca de la relación entre el
lenguaje y la desigualdad
ni el médico ni la psiquiatra tenían
malas intenciones al contrario yo
querían de todo corazón que sus
pacientes tuvieran la mejor salud
posible
al médico no se le pasaba por la cabeza
que una pareja de adultos que iba a su
consultorio no conociera la palabra
gastroenteritis para la psiquiatra que
había nacido y se había criado en un
barrio de clase media de la ciudad de
buenos aires- era impensable que un
paciente no fuera hablante nativo del
español
es decir lo que les falló a los dos fue
la imagen que se hicieron del otro y
esto nos pasa todo el tiempo porque
pensamos que nuestra manera de hablar es
la manera normal es la normal es decir
te hablo a vos como pienso que vos
deberías hablar y no necesariamente como
vos lo haces si recuerdas la historia de
antonio el agente sanitario recordarán
que él dice que le tenía malaria dolor
de barriga dolor de estómago dolor de
panza se acuerdan al usar estas
expresiones lo que antonio hace es
tratar de acomodar su habla a la nuestra
trata de encontrar las palabras que
resuelven mejor en nosotros y de esa
manera asegurarse de que estamos en la
misma sintonía
por su parte carlos con todo su guaraní
adentro no se queda callado cuando le
dicen que tiene alexitimia que tiene
dificultades para comunicarse esta
ilustración horrible con todo el estigma
de la salud mental viendo del campo una
ciudad enorme extranjero en un
consultorio médico hacía falta muy
buenos motivos para no quedarse callado
para no hacer como yo que me fui con con
este papel que no me dice nada pero
carlos no se quedó callado y en esa
frase tan breve en castellano me cuesta
lo que hizo fue hacer visible una
situación de desigualdad lingüística y
darle la psiquiatra las herramientas
para entenderla tratar de remediar la
no sé si podemos sacar una moraleja de
todo esto porque lo que cuenta lo que
muestra en estas historias es que no nos
relacionamos con la abstracción es con
conclusiones generales nos lanzamos con
personas concretas todos y todas y todos
estuvimos alguna vez en esa situación
con un abogado o una abogada que nos
habla bien entendido lo que nos decía
cuando vamos a la ferretería y pedimos
el pendón 8 para el pirulito y nos
hablan como si estuviéramos en la nasa o
como cuando tratamos de explicar o que
nos expliquen cómo hacer un trámite cómo
será un formulario cómo navegar una
página web
se le ocurren tres cosas para que el
lenguaje no sea un obstáculo
no alcanza con las buenas intenciones
necesitamos pensar críticamente con
quién estoy hablando qué cosas puedes
saber qué cosas no qué palabras
expresiones incluso lenguas pueden ser
mejores para comunicarnos y cuáles
pueden ser un problema
hagamos como antonio a como demos
nuestra habla al habla del otro
especialmente cuando estamos en
posiciones de poder cuando la asimetría
está de nuestro lado
pero también hagamos como carlos no nos
quedemos callados no nos dejemos hablar
ni por el poder ni por las instituciones
no hace falta gestos heroicos
grandilocuentes yo por ejemplo volvía al
consultorio y le pedí a mi médica que me
aclara la letra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]